You're an You're an intellectual coward.
Do not come close. This is my This is my
arm reach. This is my arm reach. Please
do not Please do not come forward. Don't
come in my I'm going to have to defend
myself.
God is
[Music]
that the questions that you are asking
actually are very fundamental questions
that can be asked about any religion.
Yes. It could be asked about anyone. And
and what I'm saying is that there is a
truth and with these basic questions to
any of the religions it could help us
get to the truth. Asking these questions
what do you want to prove? Uh want want
to show that there is no substance
within Islam. The only substance is
Jesus Christ. After we show there's no
substance in Islam, we give you the
gospel and show you how the substance is
Jesus. But that would be also said by uh
uh Jewish traditions as well. Well, no.
So here's the thing. I would challenge
the Jew as well. our child is a Jew and
say why uh do you refuse to believe in
the Messiah you know and what evidences
do you have to reject Jesus as the
Messiah and why do you think so anyone
should believe that Messiah is a prophet
and Muslims the prophet who came from
Isaac's bloodline is not a prophet how
does it make sense to you talking about
uh Mosh Muhammad well be because for
Muhammad to say that he's a prophet
right he makes certain claims he says he
didn't make claims he did he said that
he's mentioned in the previous
scriptures in the Quran. In the Quran?
No. No. Actually, the thing is that
which which part of the Quran? Which
chapter you are? Chapter you got chapter
7 verse 157. Which verse? 157. Yeah.
What? What? Give me 137. Yeah. So, it
says uh No, just read to me in Arabic.
In Arabic. Why do I got to read it to
you in Arabic? Because this Quran is in
Arabic. Do you do you speak Arabic?
Yeah. Or do you want to see it in
Arabic? No, you have to actually read it
to me. I No, I don't. I could just give
it to you in an No, no, I'm a re. So
you're you're saying that I can't
understand the Quran without I didn't
make such claim. What I'm saying is I'm
a researcher and if you just tell me
something in English without kind of
putting an emphasis on the scripture on
in which it was written doesn't make
sense. No, what I'm saying is is that
even in the English translation, let me
let me finish. No, I'm not just asking
about the translation. I I know I know.
Let me respond what you're saying. Okay.
Because I'm hearing what you're saying.
You're saying that the importance is in
the the source language, right? I have
to understand the source language in
order to even really consider this and
talk about the verses, right? No, I talk
about that. I Well, that's what you kind
of said. I can't quote I can't You're
saying I can't tell you about a verse in
the Quran without Arabic. No, no. What
I'm saying is if you are talking about a
particular verse, you are giving me a
reference point. Yes. From a much more
academic perspective. You have to
actually read that reference to me. Yes.
And also the kind of context that you
are actually making here. You have to
also let tell me the genealogy of those
concepts which have been used in I don't
have to. The only thing I got to do is
just show you what the Quran says. If
the Quran says Yeah. If the Quran says
in chap chapter 7 I'm telling you. No
chapter I'm telling you. No. I mean do
you want me to show you the book? Yeah.
Oh, I got you. Look. No. No. You have to
show me the evidence of the book and the
translation. What do you mean the
evidence of the book? Are you a Muslim?
No. Oh, then what are you talking about
there? Oh my gosh. He is he is telling
me I'm going to talk about chapter 7. I
said okay. You're talking about You
asked me where the You asked me where
the claim was. Show me and tell me the
translation because I don't know
anything about it. I'm trying to but you
keep cutting me off. No. Okay. Just tell
me. Okay. So, so just to be clear, you
want me to show you the verse that I'm
talking about. Okay. Here we go. He did
ask you that and you said no. Yeah. Oh,
okay.
So, here. First of all, it's in English.
I actually don't think so. Do you read
Arabic? Yeah. Okay. Do you want me to
hand you a Arabic Quran so you can go to
the verse for me? Yeah, you have to.
See, I'm a student. I'm a student. If
you're a student, I asked you this
earlier. You told me no. Okay. Show me
the verse here. Oh, no. Show me. No, I I
trust you. You read Arabic, right? I
don't. You don't read Arabic, do you?
Yeah. Okay. So, go to the verse for me.
No, no. What I what I'm saying is it's
not my Actually, I have to go to the
verse because I'm Yes, you are. No, it
is you because you are making No, you're
making the claim that I can't give you a
verse without Arabic. Yeah, give me. So,
no, I don't I reject that claim. Do I do
I have Can I Can I know what the Quran
says without Arabic? You have to
actually show me in this chapter. Why?
Because you are telling me telling you
what I'm following you. What's my claim?
Your claim is in the chapter seven and
prophet is making claim. Yeah. Certain
claim. So all I got to do is show you
chapter seven in the verse, right? Yeah.
Okay. So I don't need to do this with
this one. I can show you from this,
right? Why? Cuz it says it in the book.
You actually want to take you're you're
playing games, bro. Oh my god. You're
playing games. First of all, you should
go to school. I I think you should, too.
No, no, no. Actually, I I I think so.
You need to uh learn the art of
debating. I I I think you do when when
you when you when you say when you make
a claim and you and you and then I
provide for you the evidence and you
say, "Well, no, I don't want that." And
then wait, let me finish. See, the art
of debate is letting people speak,
right? Let let me just No, no, no. I I
just I listen to you this whole time.
So, what I'm saying is this. When you
ask me for an evidence of what I said
and then I'm about to provide for you
the evidence and then you and then you
No, no. Let me finish. Right. No. Again,
see, you're talking about You're talking
about You're talking about the art of
debate and you're not even doing this.
No, you are. You're talking about the
art of debate and you're just talking
over me. Show me the I'm going to show
I'm going to show you. I'm I'm going to
show I'm going to show you what the
Quran says cuz I'm I'm about to teach
you. I'm about to teach you what the
Quran says cuz you got to go to school
for this. Bro, have you have you
actually read philosophy? I got you
right here. No, no, I cannot read
anything. Those who follow the
unlettered prophet whom they find
written in the Torah and the Gospel. So
according to the Quran, I'm supposed to
find Muhammad written in the Torah and
Gospel, right? Oh, this is corrupted.
No, no, I'm not saying it's corrupted.
Yeah, you are. Is it corrupted or not?
Is it true? See, I I don't make any
claims whether it's asking I'm asking
you right now. Is it true? No. What you
have? So, it's corrupted. No. No. What
you have to do is first if you are
actually aligning me about something.
You have to go to the source language
and tell me this is the verse where the
prophet. He already tried to do that.
You reject it. No, no, no. The source
language is Arabic. We have it right
here. I handed I handed it to you to try
to show you and you rejected it. No, I
Why do you want me to show it to you?
Because you read the language. Do you
not? You don't read the language. I
don't read the language. Then how can
you make the claim? I don't have to know
the language to be able to read the
Quran. So basically what you're saying
is this. If I don't know Arabic, I can't
read the Quran. That's what you're
saying, right? No. This see right there.
Don't say no. You're not saying that
when you just said that. In order to
understand any context, any society, any
culture, any mythological genealogy of
concepts, you have to first of all put
an emphasis on the on the original
language. Right. Exactly. Whether it's
Hebrew, whether it's Arabic, whether
it's any form of language because you
have to understand in translation when
you translate any original text into
another language there is a lot of
debate on that. We do not have those
kind of sophistications or linguistic
conceptual tools to available to
understand or to even accurately
translate original texts into another
language. Sir, it's not about me. It's
about people who talk about this
vidinstein, Walter Benjamin, Michel
Fuku, all of these French thinkers like
there is a huge literature on this. It's
not do do they translate their works?
What do you say? Do they transl these
authors you've just mentioned these do
they translate their works? These are
the people who talk about why
translation is impossible. Do they are
their works translated? No, they're not
translated. They're translated. But that
does not mean Wait, you said they are
translated. So what is the point? If
he's saying that translation is
impossible, why is they having their
works translated so people can know what
they're saying? Their works are
translated. But what what I'm also
saying is a proper actually debate where
you cannot literally translate original
language into foreign language in order
to understand the meaning because you
have to go back to the context whether
it's I'm not talking about Quran I'm not
talking about I'm talking about any
culture right just in general yeah if
you go to any let's say African
continent you go to any society as a as
an sociologist as an anthropologist you
go there you understand your culture in
their own language you don't actually
tell them, "Oh, I know English. I want
you to speak to me in English." You go
there, you actually learn their customs.
You learn their tradition. Do they when
you when when the people go there and
they speak with like the chieftains or
uh the tribal leaders or people, you
know, do they have a translator to
communicate to help them communicate
with the cultures? What I'm see that's
that's a different question. What I'm
That's not a different question. I heard
everything. But I don't Well, yeah, but
you're you're changing the subject. No,
I'm not. I'm actually understanding. You
got to listen. Pay attention to what
he's saying. No, what I'm telling he's
saying that you cannot understand a
culture outside of their language.
Clearly. No. No. Actually, I I'm just
telling you if you go to any society,
any society in the world in order to
understand a particular society, you
have to understand their vernacular
language. I understand what you're
saying. Understand your traditions. I
understand. You cannot just go into a
society and tell my I heard you. I heard
what you said. I heard what you said.
What my argument was. So you just going
to keep going?
[Music]
I don't think that you're interested in
actual intellectual debate. You have to
go to the original language. You cannot
just tell me this is the vers and I
quote you in English. That's a
self-defeating argument. It is about
Hebrew. It's about it's a self-defeating
argument. You're talking about Hinduism.
You have to read Sanskrit in order to
understand Hinduism. This is called
confirmation bias right here. Actually
western his point is I heard I heard his
point. Doesn't matter if it's a
religious text or not. Yeah. You got to
understand the original language.
Straight history. You got to understand
the original language. That's his point,
right? No, it's deeper than that. No.
So, oh my goodness. For for for what you
guys are saying. Hold on. Cuz I cuz I
just I just I know, but I just heard
him. I'm about to respond to him. I'm
about to respond to him. I'm about to My
good sir, respectfully, I'm about to
respond to what he just said. Just
respectfully. Oh,
no. See, no worries. I'm going to say
what exactly what he said. His point is
you in order for you to make a comment
or even understand somebody's text, you
need to understand the language. Hold
on. I'm I'm still talking though. Notice
how notice how rude this is, right? Did
I Did I let him speak? I I sat here and
listened to his point. Did I not speak?
No, I know. I was responding to him.
You're coming into our conversation. So,
I was already talking to him. I know.
But for for I don't think that you guys
know how conversation works. For a
conversation to happen, we listen to
each other. I just listened to him,
right? You did you witness me listen to
him? Listening to both of you. That's
fine. I'm asking you. Did you witness me
listen to him? I heard both of you. No.
Did you watch me let him speak? I
watched both of you speak and I heard
That's not That's what I'm asking you.
My question is very simple. Did you or
did you not watch me sit here quietly
while he made his point?
Thank you, Con. I'm glad you said that.
You won't let me say anything. Okay, I'm
done with you now. So, I'm done with
you. So, according cuz you can't even be
honest here. So according to what you're
saying, yeah, I'm talking to you.
According to what you're saying, you
just say that you cannot understand a
language. You can't understand a culture
unless you know the language here. But
but he's talking about people who have
their stuff translated. He said
translation is impossible. So then I
asked her, "Okay, do you want the
Arabic?" You don't want the Arabic,
right? You're a joke. You're a clown.
You're a clown. No. No, you're not. No,
you're not. Get on out of here. You're
not. No, you're not. You can you can
claim whatever you want, too.
So, so do you want to do you want to
engage and do outreach by attacking
Islam? Really? Wait, hold on. What did
Jesus do? How did he do his outreach?
Outreach to the Pharisees?
How did he do his outreach? All of a
sudden, you want to talk to me when you
had just cut. No, you just No, you cut
me off. You said that you answer the
question. I'm engaging with you. It's
you now. It's not engaging. Are you
about to put your back on and run away
now? That's what I thought. Are you
going to let me speak? I just asked you
a question. I'm going to listen to you.
When Jesus did his outreach to the
Pharisees, how did he do it?
number one. I'd prefer to go back to the
deeper point. That's not what I asked.
Oh, let me just tell you. So, you made a
claim about how to do outreach, but you
don't want to respond to it. He was
saying that when you translate any text,
whether it's religious, you're ignoring
the question. Whether it's just a
historical, brother, you're ignoring the
question. When you translate For us to
have a fruitful conversation, we have to
engage, bro. To another language, we
have to engage.
See, no, you're right. Yeah. No, he's
running away. He's done. He's done. to
two enlightened men, right? You're
enlightened, right? Yes, you are. You're
proving your ignorance to two
enlightened men, right? You're
enlightened. Both of you guys are
enlightened because you're missing the
deeper point and you won't even let me
say it. Well, I let you say things, I
question you on it, and then you change
the subject, and you ignore it. I'm
saying to you, the point I'm making,
yeah, you're very enlightened. The point
I'm making is that any I think you're
here to argue, you you translate
any text, very enlightened, any text
to another language. Uh-huh. It doesn't
translate all the way. Right. At all. At
all. So So very good. Very good. So then
what you're saying is tell me what I'm
saying. No. No. Okay. You know what? My
fault. Can I Can I ask you Can I Can I
ask you now? Can I ask you based on what
you just said? Stop. Stop. I'm talking
to him. Stop. Stop. I'm talking about
him. I'm talking to him. Get out of
here. I'm talking to him. So ba based on
what you based on what you said, do I
have to know Arabic to be able to read
the Quran? Do I have to know Arabic to
read the crime? Fight your death. I
could fight off. Hello. Whatever. Hello.
Whatever. Hello. It's not Hello. Look at
this. You're so You're so enlightened,
but you can't have a conversation. This
is a war. You're so enlightened, but you
can't have a conversation. You're done.
This guy a couple weeks ago, brother.
You're done. I'm done talking to you.
I'm done. I know you're not. You're
treat. Let's go right now then. Oh,
look. Look at this. You're enlightened,
right? Let's go. You're enlightened,
right? No. No. You said coward. Let's
[__] go. You're an You're an
intellectual coward. Do not come close.
This is my This is my arm reach. This is
my arm reach. Please do not Please do
not come forward. Don't come in my I'm
going to have to defend myself
down. Yep. I'm going have to defend
myself. Then start the fight. I will
have to defend myself if you come in my
space. Personal space. That's right. I
said I'll take both. Yeah.
Yeah. This is a This is cowardice. When
you when you can't engage
intellectually, this is how you got to
act. You're a coward. I don't want to
hear it. What would you want to do?
You're in my All these Antichrist
spirits. You walked up. Hey. Hey,
brother. You need You need Jesus, bro. I
wish you would. You need Jesus, bro. In
my personal space. You need Jesus, bro.
You need to back up. You need to back
up. You need You already It's been
caught on tape. It's been caught on
tape. Appreciate it. You need Jesus,
bro. Here you go. You need Jesus, bro.
Don't be coward. So, I'm talking about
Yeah. You're an intellectual coward,
bro. You're intellectual. You won't even
listen to me. That's why you're the I
listen to you and then you didn't
listen. You're the You're done. You're
done. We're done with I saw you a couple
weeks ago. What's up, brother? You got a
question? Brother, my brother just enter
Just entertain my brother. That's why
it's a war. The ones that back down.
Take care of peace. It's not whatever.
It's war. You know how many people are
dying every night? I do. Keep that to
yourself. You know where the bodies are.
Keep that to yourself. You know where
the bodies are buried? Where's yours
going to be? Go ahead. Yeah.
Keep it. So, you just proved yourself
enemies. Keep it stepping, baby. Keep
take care of yourself, man. God bless
you, bro. God loves you, man. Repent of
your sin, bro. God takes care of me. He
does. You got to turn to him now. He
says he has no sin. But all three of you
is a liar and the truth is not in it.
I'm talking about who says he does has
not dynamic right now. I haven't sinned
against it. The truth is not in. I
haven't sinned against you. I'm talking
about I'm pray I'm praying for you, man.
I'm praying for you, bro. I'm praying
for you. All right. Take care. I don't
care how you interpret
because take care of yourself ignorant.
Take care of yourself. I know you're
intellectually you can't do an outreach
in the name of Yeshua. Take care of
yourself by attacking Islam. You're on a
different level. I agree with you. You
are on a different level. Yes.
Completely. Take care. Take care of
yourself. Take your different level.
Take your different level and keep on
going. That's the one truth. Whatever.
Right. I know. I know. Take care of
yourself now.
You're a fraud. Byebye. And you're weak.
Bye-bye. And you can't even listen to
the truth. And I would take all three of
you and you know it, right? All you have
to do is start.
You can giggle all you want. You can
giggle giggle. Haha. He he. I would take
all three of you. Right. Right. Right.
There was nothing you could do with me.
Right. Uh-huh. Take care. Take care of
yourself, man. Take care. Have a good
day. You know, you made it over there
and then you came back. A big scene.
Five. This is This is the Antichrist
spirit right here, man. Jumping at any
opportunity to try to fight Christians
and disturb the gospel. Middle finger.
Christian. Middle finger. I didn't say
anything about Christianing. You said
you know. You said you know Y. I didn't
say that. You can't know Y without See,
you haven't heard a word I said. I saw
the middle in your mind. Keep going,
man. And you're the prejudice. You're
the racist. Keep going. You're the
racist. Okay. just prove the point,
right? Okay.
Manifest.
That's what happens, man. You got you
got you got Muslims trying to fake to be
Christians. Don't want to announce who
they really are. You got uh I don't want
to talk to him. You got just Antichrist,
period. He fake all Christian. He's not
No, he's not. You You need to You need
to know the original language in order
to even make say something about the
book. Okay, here's the original
language. Read it for me. He doesn't say
what? No. No. I don't know that. No, you
do it now. Get out of here, man. You're
a clown. You've been exposed. You can't
even deal with this. Can't be
intellectually challenged on a UC
campus. Come on now. Come on, man. What
we doing here, man?
Oh my god. Logic.
[Music]